good morning everybody and thanks for
joining me today my name is Stephanie
Kim I'm a developer with the Apollo
education group we have an office in
Seattle that I work out it today we're
going to talk about how to investigate
user experience with natural language
processing and analysis so first we're
just going to go over some broad
definitions of what I'll be talking
about and then we'll kind of go into
more of you know how to help the user
through learning what issues they might
be having with your UI so first natural
language processing it's the field of
computer science decade the
understanding natural language through
machine learning and computational
linguistics and when I talk about
natural language i'm talking about
everyday human spoken language versus
artificial language such as programming
languages like Python so blah blah blah
what does that all mean and it means we
can use statistical models and
probabilistic algorithms stance or
business questions to make informative
decisions and there's a little cartoon
from XKCD he wasn't really happy with
her graph so but anyway she was trying
to prove her point with data she kind of
did but not how she wanted so why do we
need data to tell us what to do and
there's a lot of talk about data driven
design our decision making I don't
really like that terminology I like it
more to be data in form a informative
like you want your data to inform you
about what your users are doing but not
necessarily take it as complete truth so
first of all you'd be really surprised
at what the user is thinking doing and
having problems with that you might not
realize
so through feedback form data you can
actually gain some insight to that but
you actually have to do some analysis on
that feedback form data not just throw
it throw the feedback you know form on
your website you know kind of forget
about it you actually have to look at
the comments and look at what people are
saying users actually have some pretty
cool insights and suggestions for making
your product better they're the ones
that use it every day and you know they
they might have a simple suggestion like
hey I can't find this link or you know
oh hey could you put this feature on
that would really be helpful and and if
they're thinking it probably a lot of
other people are too so you can also
gauge how releases affect user sentiment
because you can do like a time series
analysis and you can look at sentiment
and break it down by release states and
that's kind of interesting to see how
like maybe a big design changes of
change effects effects you know the
users sediment and how they are thinking
about your site I and you can also find
we don't like to admit anything gets
passed QA that it does you can find bugs
and design issues that might have been
missed and of course you know with all
these new insights and all this great
user feedback you can gain opportunities
to run a B test based off the actual
feedback instead of just maybe the
business owners intuition
so what is the user thinking are they
happy sad super pissed off we should
really find out don't you think I'd like
to know what my users are thinking about
my product so our goal is to find
possible points of friction in general
user sentiment of textual data so it's a
as a developer by the way I should say a
little bit about my background I'm a
developer not a data scientist not an
analyst Neistat it's it's a lot to learn
as a developer we don't have data
scientists we have analysts but I took
on this project because I had the time
and I know python and a little bit of
our and i can write sequel queries so
that's how i got to do it so first you
want to identify your data set so where
is it coming from is it coming from say
adobe analytics API is it coming from
the csv file or the database straight
from the database how big is your data
set and that can affect what model you
might choose how much pre-processing
doesn't need generally you generally use
your comments need a lot of
pre-processing um you need to figure out
about dropping empty records filtering
out testing IP addresses there's just a
lot of cleaning up that you probably
need to do so next you need to identify
the tools you will need and this can
kind of be a little bit I mean it's
really great because there's all these
great tools and you know not only Python
tools but you know our tools as well but
you want to focus on solving your
problem and not get caught up on what
everybody is using at the time you know
everybody's talking about this algorithm
or that one so you want to you know you
want to read the forums and tutorials to
kind of figure out how to solve your
problem and not get caught up on you
know what's the latest
topic so this one is pretty important
because it will decide on your structure
of your scripts so you want to decide
whether your report will be automated or
ad hoc you want to figure out how often
will you run it sometimes business
owners will be like oh we want this run
daily and you're like no that's not
going to gain any insight so you might
want to run it weekly especially for
feedback form data because you know
users are commenting on a daily basis
but you know say your sprints run two to
three weeks so I feel like a weekly a
weekly turn out that is pretty good for
gaining insights and catching maybe
things that you want to catch in a
timely manner and so if it's automated
you also need to think about whether you
want to use tools such as ipython
notebook it's great for you know quick
iteration and development prototyping
but you know if you do want to automate
it you're going to have to take you know
what you did and make it into a script
that will won't irritate the next person
that will come and try to work on your
code so
next we're going to talk about
methodology Houston text mining so
you've got categorization of features
and you've got information retrieval and
both are useful but they're kind of
useful in different ways categorization
and features you've got cluster analysis
and that's a good way to find patterns
in your data that you might have missed
such as clusters of terms that are
commonly found near each other in a
vector I space sentiment analysis which
is probably the majority of what we're
going to be talking about today I'm
using a supervised machine learning
models such as then I Bayes classifier
or you can also use a lexicon based
approach determine how users are feeling
about your product this actually ended
up being one of my favorites and pretty
insightful as the time series analysis
so you can monitor user sentiment based
on release dates as I talked about
earlier other variables to identify
changes over time so you can also do the
lexical dispersion so you just take the
most frequent words with maintaining
order of those words in the corpus to
determine the most talked-about terms
through time and it also can be
separated via sentiment classification
so normally like a lexical dispersion
plot would show you the word offset but
because you're you're maintaining that
word order you can also kind of look at
the most frequent words how they change
from like say two months ago to now
especially like if you're separating it
and sentiment classification you can
have a negative classification plot and
a positive one and see okay how many
times did we see difficult can't or
won't let me because you know you can
all you don't have to use just yoona
grams you can use by grams or trigram so
look at kind of word phrases and stuff
so informational information retrieval
so this ended up being after of course
you do the sentiment analysis this I
felt was the most beneficial even though
it was like the two smallest functions i
wrote for this project so basically
you're just taking word frequency in the
corpus you're not maintaining word order
you're not carrying about grammar and
you just apply a search functionality
finding those frequent comments and I
found about like the top 25 to 30
comments or I'm sorry the top 25 to 30
most frequent words searching for those
in your corpus and you're in the
comments those comments you have to then
manually read and there you can find
different issues that are common with
those frequent terms and those frequent
firms aren't always opinion words a lot
of times they're they're about your
product and so it's actually really
beneficial to look it and read and yeah
there is manual work in it and that's
but that manual work is will definitely
give you way more insight than any you
know visualization or model will show
you
so how can machine learning help us do
all this normally a lot of times you
hear a machine learning for image
detection today I'm filtering providing
recommendations for customers with a
recommendation engine speech detection
and then of course natural language
processing so I just felt like we needed
a cute little animal so I put this
machine learning to the rescue so yeah
there's aa you'd have to label a lot of
your data to get really useful insight
and that's why machine learning is great
because you don't have to label all your
data so here I just I look for you know
through dozens of definitions of machine
learning and I hate it almost all of
them because they were either really
technical or just really dry um I found
this from lecture notes and I just
thought it was a really human friendly
way to describe machine learning so it's
machine learning studies computer
algorithms for learning to do stuff we
might for instance be interested in
learning to complete a task or makeup
accurate predictions or behave
intelligently the learning that is being
done is always based on some sort of
observations or data such as examples
direct experience or instruction so in
general machine learning is about
learning to do better in the future
based on what we experienced in the past
and so the main point is you know you're
trying to automate decision-making with
computers
so first I'm going to talk about
unsupervised machine learning because
it's a lot of times used for exploratory
analysis so it's kind of a good starting
point if you really don't know much
about your data so the key points of
that make it an unsupervised model
versus a super by his novel or that
training data is unlabeled beforehand
it's used to find underlying structure
of data based on statistical properties
such as frequency it's used for
exploratory analysis find unrealized
patterns and it's used when there's a
lack of labeled training documents so
there's just some examples of models i
have seen maximum entropy classified as
a supervisor model and unsupervised so i
guess it depends upon what academic
papers you read so i'm going to be
talking about k-means clustering a
little bit here so it's used again for
relationship discovery and understand
that underlying structure of data it's
useful for unlabeled data is the first
round of analysis it makes no
assumptions on the data it manually you
manually have to give it a target number
of clusters and that's usually done
using the elbow method it's you it
utilizes distance metric and clustering
algorithm so its objective is to
minimize the average squared euclidean
distance and yeah so there's tons of
tools like there's so many good python
user developer-friendly tools to use to
accomplish model it you know running
models such as the k-means cluster
scikit-learn and NLT kr2 and the psyche
it learns t fi de vectorize ER or word
to vac lie
or the word tyvek library can be used to
vectorize words giving textual content
and numeric value because I was the one
thing you need to the key means it has
to be numeric value so I actually didn't
find this to be entirely that useful it
gave me some cool groupings for you know
frequent terms but then it was you look
at that and you're like okay well what
can I do with that information and it is
kind of interesting you know to see okay
well this term is you know near that
term but beyond interesting I didn't
find it useful so supervised machine
learning so what makes it supervise
let's see classes the classifier is
called supervised if it's built based on
training corpora and corpora is just if
I haven't explained that before um it's
it's just your text content so core pod
could be like you know census or it
could be a book or comments in our case
so it can the Train corpora has to
contain the correct label for each input
it's used when a large number of labeled
training documents are available and
here's some examples of popular
supervised machine learning models so
i'll be talking about the naive bayes
classification it's the one that you
know when i was looking on what model to
use to classify sentiment this one came
up a lot and so i gave it a try and it
actually did pretty good it the lexicon
based non machine learning method does
actually about the same for me for my
don't
same but anyway so when used for
sentiment classification and the inputs
are classified in isolation having no
effect on other inputs meaning their
atomic one doesn't affect the other
labels are assigned in advance and
that's kind of the tough one because
that's a lot of manual work you want to
you want to create a training and you
want to create training data that's
based off your domain and so you
actually have to go through like in my
example doing sentiment analysis you
have to go through comments and score
those yourself I did try to use other
training data to cheat and it doesn't
work very well feature detection is
decided in advance and that's one of the
most important ways to increase the
accuracy of your model and a lot of
times it's just narrow down by trial and
error trying to identify features that
result in a classifier with our accuracy
and you can do this with engrams so you
know grams by grams and trigrams
stemming stop words I found like that
yoona grams performed really well a
stemming decreased accuracy and stemming
is just taking a word to the to the root
and stop words you can either include
stop words English stop words or
articles or you can exclude them and
those are you know just words that are
commonly found in the English language
like to but so those can be included and
excluded and classifiers are created by
training them on labeled data so again
the natural language processing kit
contains a naive bayes classifier to
classify data based on train data it
it's just again super easy all these
tools are really easy to use once you
figure out what you're supposed to be
doing in the first place it includes
perceived accuracy and likelihood ratios
for comparing future top come
relationships the perceived accuracy I
mean that's actually and that's taken
from from their book it is perceived
because when you manually go through and
check accuracy it's it's definitely not
as accurate as the models for seeing it
to be but I should say that humans only
agree on sentiment about I think I've
read eighty percent of the time and so
if you your models about sixty nine
seventy percent from what I've read from
academic papers that's usually pretty
good I think two different Stanford
papers say 60 to 65 actually acceptable
which seems really bad but you can still
gain insight so I also tested against
the lexicon based non machine learning
method so it's it relies this method
relies on sentiment lexicon and it
matches terms in a dictionary with those
in your corpus a lot of times focuses on
just adjectives so those are opinion
words with their labeled sentiment i do
want to point out that i mean there's
there's a lot of dictionaries out there
that you can use like there's a thin
text for twitter sentiment whatnot but
you can start with those but it's really
really important to add and customize
those dictionaries by adding domain
specific terms because there's a lot of
terminology that is in your your data
your comments the regular dictionary is
going to misconstrue is either positive
or negative so say you've got a product
that has the word interest
in it or yeah yeah interest um well
interest in you know these dictionaries
these sentiment dictionaries is a
positive word well what if it's just a
it's just a pronoun in your terminology
in your domain then you need to kind of
neutralize that or else you'll it'll you
know the debt the the scoring will be
skewed so so there's also another way of
doing that's the manual creation of a
dictionary meaning someone went in and
took words such as great happy sad and
gave them either numeric value on a
scale from Lake you know negative 52
positive 5 with neutral beam 0 or it
could be a string positive neutral
negative but there's also the automatic
creation of dictionary and that way
starts as a list of seed words using
statistical means such as point wise
mutual information and that it just
associates a word with a set of positive
and negative seed words to find synonyms
and antonyms in the corpus
so how easy is it to properly classify
data this pretty much sums it up can
everybody read that or should I read it
to you guys when a user takes a photo
the app should check whether they're in
a national park and of course this is a
business owner I'm assuming sure easy
GIS look up give me a few hours oh and
check whether the photos of a bird the
developer says they'll need a research
team in five years and yeah the bottom
it says in CS it can be hard to explain
the difference between the easy and the
virtually impossible and so yeah I'm a
developer probably some of you are to
not raise their signs that we're not all
research scientist institutions so why
aren't we leaving it up to the experts
well do you have a team every search
scientist on board I know my company
doesn't can you afford to pay vendors
for their software well maybe but
there's also additional work that needs
to be done like I've talked about to
customize the reporting but maybe only
internal developers and analysts will
know about such as what I was talking
about you know specific words in your
that are in your domain that will skew
the results if they're not either
removed or neutralized and really why
let someone else have all the fun
because it is it's really it's a fun
type of project and you get to help your
user based off their direct feedback
which actually feels pretty amazing
so accuracy and as I talked a little bit
before about what's acceptable for
accuracy this part is developer will
cause you to fall down the rabbit hole
more than anything in this type of
project because you can always tweak it
you're always learning something to make
it better so at some point you just have
to stop and say okay this is good we've
you know gained a lot of insights and
then of course you know in a couple
weeks can always back and tweak it some
more if you really want to so there's
air checking and model validation so
there's if you choose to have too many
features I think the NLP k K's example
is gender identification of first names
and so a feature would be the last
letter of that name and whether it ends
in a wire and asks I can't remember the
details of that but when you take the
first letter as well as the last letter
having more than one feature it actually
decreases the accuracy of the model so
that can and can cause the overfitting
so what engrams are more accurate from
what i've read i wish i had have read it
before I did it before I played around
with it so much but you know grams tend
to actually be more accurate than say by
grams or trigrams so one word versus
like two or three words and that's the
trick I mean you have to find it the the
right information to read before you
start these projects too and sometimes
you just come along stuff and you're
like oh I wish I hadn't known that soda
stemming help or hinder the process I am
again this has been found to this is a
real quick there's a you know
in the natural language processing kit
it it's it's really easy to apply so
it's really fast to figure out whether
this actually is going to help you or
decrease accuracy and then stop words do
we include or exclude them this one is a
little bit trickier because it kind of
depends upon the model that you use to
and so yeah you're checking with using
confusion and matrices and cross
validation to check accuracy and compare
models and again I think the
scikit-learn has that yeah it does it
has this too and the natural language
toolkit has it as well so you don't have
to write those that functionality
yourself it's all built into the tools
so someone told me I needed more visuals
in the slides so this is what I made I
suck at visuals so but it's a visual
with text so it just kind of goes with
goes through the workflow a little bit
um you're wanting to do for his data
extraction and preprocessing and I've
kind of talked about some of this stuff
before feature selection and extraction
and negation modifiers is really
important and that's why I expected by
grams to be more useful than you know
grams because not good changes the
meaning of good and such so that
actually kind of surprised me but then
yeah you've got implement your
classifier after you've you know of
course you have to choose that
classifier first based on what your data
looks like and there are some options
and I just started reading about maximum
entropy and I don't know enough about it
to really explain it but from what I've
read it a lot of times beats the naive
bayes classifier so I'm going to try
that one
so right now it's classification model
should i use for sentiment analysis
there is no easy answer because it
depends upon your domain it depends upon
how much data you have but the basics
are how much time can you commit to this
project is this going to be you know
some you know hurried like half-ass you
know projects that you do on the side or
are you going to really be able to
dedicate a couple months to two you know
learning and doing this because each
model takes a different amount of time
to set up and also it eat model takes a
different amount of time to understand
the underlying algorithm and it is
important to understand what each model
is doing so you understand which you
know some of the different features that
might help that algorithm like the naive
Bayes needs yoona grams so that's
something that's really important to
know before you start playing around
with the different features so I found
that the lexical based approach is the
easiest to understand you're just
matching you're you know you're just
matching terms in here your text two
terms in a dictionary and grabbing the
sentiment of those terms so that's
obviously a super basic and easy to
understand the naive Bayes is probably I
think the easiest of the probabilistic
models to understand and it's it does
take more time to set up because you
have to label your data and it's
sometimes you don't have to personally
do it but sometimes it's hard to wrangle
other people to do it whether their
business owners or developers but I
think it's important you know to get
more than just yourself labeling news
because as I said about roughly eighty
percent humans actually agree on
sentiment
of words or whole sentences so maximum
entropy out of these examples probably
takes the longest of the three to set up
and it's more complicated to understand
but since i've read recently that it
sometimes beats then I face classifier
I'm definitely going to take the time to
look into that and learn about it more
so what about accuracy every models
accuracy changes based on the domain and
training data used and again I said you
know like you can't use movie review
comment sentiment and expect it as your
training data set and expect it to be
really accurate for say user feedback
comments because it's not I try how big
is your data small data set and you want
to stick to high bias algorithms that
will more likely cause underfitting
versus high variance algorithms that
will over fit and remember feature
selection will affect the algorithm as
well and there's no there aren't a lot
of good answers on this like I searched
everywhere about you know what's the
best one and it seems like everybody's
playing with everything so in most of
these once you get your data
pre-processed and it actually goes
pretty fast in it once you understand
like the basics of the tools understand
the underlying algorithms and models you
know that that that doesn't take as long
as you might think it does so I'm going
to quickly go over a few more slides
that I found really beneficial so
there's the time series analysis so
after you've got your sentiment your
user sentiment you can discover how it
changes over time and find problem areas
due to spikes and negative feedback or
even you know look at wow like after
this release there is this huge spike in
positive feedback like we are doing
something right
which always feels very validating so
the those are the benefits and then how
well you get the sentiment using one the
classification models you group the
comments by neutral positive or negative
sediment and you group comments by day
week month or year and then you can
integrate release dates as markers to
gauge sentiment change after a major
design changes but i do want to point
out you still want to be testing your
designs was real users using ad tests
you shouldn't just rely on you know
something like this to to see you want
to be more proactive than that with new
design changes with the lexical
dispersion plot which I kind of
described earlier the benefits to that
or you gain knowledge about word offset
in your corpus so you can identify
changes through time for engrams and
positive or negative um text so you can
as I said you can split that lexical
dispersion and a positive or negative um
yeah so you get sentiment using one of
the classification models plot using the
NLT k tool dispersion plot method and
then use engrams that stand out for
information retrieval of comments with
recent high counts of negative comments
so yeah if you if you're if you're
seeing a lot of like can't well don't
like you know a lot of negative terms
recent then you might want to look at
what's going on in your UI that might
have changed recently and then as I said
in the beginning information retrieval
is one of the most useful things and
then one of the most manual things and
also one of the easiest things to
implement once you have your your
sentiment so benefits by manually
reading comments that contain high
frequency terms you can focus on
patterns in the UI that users might be
having trouble with also you can find
user suggestions from these comments
containing high frequency terms and then
how use
a bag of word model and get the most
common words in the corpus and using
them to search and retrieve comments and
their sentiments for comments containing
those words all right so which model or
analysis should I use so this I just
kind of summed up what I experienced as
far as like the exploratory algorithms
were interesting but I didn't find them
to be like particularly beneficial in
exposing patterns that weren't already
obvious and the information retrieval
was definitely the most insightful tools
to get the job done so if pandas I guess
I don't really talk about pandas yet but
it'll reduce your code by at least
two-thirds like if you're using just
vanilla Python it's yeah I try first
script is with just Python and then I
learned pandas a little better and I was
like oh my gosh why didn't I learn this
earlier so you can use it has just
really cool sequel like features pivot
tables joins merges aggregating
functions and then you know the
input/output methods are really tight
too so the natural language toolkit I've
talked about a lot and it's got a book
and if you're a developer that doesn't
really know much about text mining or
natural language processing read the
book it's got great tutorials and great
information and then scikit-learn has
some great different modules for
classification algorithms clustering
modules pre-processing and I'm sure all
that you guys have heard about that so I
did put some helpful sites and articles
some of them are academic some of them
are really developer friendly so and the
slides will be posted so you guys can
check those out
so what can or what did we find about um
oh we're done okay so we're done um any
yeah wrap it up okay so I already talked
about all these points anyway so it's
just reiterating the points that we
found in the user interface and thank
you guys for coming and the slides will
be up at some point right and yeah have
fun at your other talks thank you